spiral staircases are absolutely
incredible if you missed how we made
this set of spiral staircases on arcade
24
make sure you go back to the last video
but today i'm showing you exactly how to
document it on twin motion
to export the perfect render
okay so you've made it this far you've
clearly watched the arcade 24 version of
how we modeled this exact spiral
staircase
now we're going to play a little bit
more with arcade 24 and twin motion
to make this spiral staircase look
absolutely beautiful
the best way i've found to do this is to
work continuously moving back and forth
between archicad and twin motion
so what i'll do is open up a direct link
to twin motion 2021
that is incredibly difficult to say and
i'm not going to tell you how many times
i repeated that to get it right so we're
just going to start with a new project
we're not going to mess around with any
of the settings and we're going to see
what it looks like
we've basically got our spiral staircase
in a beautiful room
with basically the sunlight coming
through because we're going to the sky
which is incorrect so what we're going
to have to do is draw an additional
layer above
what you'll notice is we also won't be
able to move far enough back we're just
going to hit into a roadblock of the
wall
so we can actually adjust the viewing
angle of this but i'd probably prefer to
actually just change and extend that
room
in archicad so we can create something
that looks really really good in twin
motion
so let's jump back to arcad go stop
showing that delete all that
move to our first floor plan clicking
control
down to move to our bottom floor plan
all i'm simply going to do
is copy those walls go one level up
paste those walls
once more go back to my 3d
so i know that i've created a secondary
floor
use my sealing tool hold the alt button
and
simply draw a top slab so i have a
ceiling and it's completely enclosed
now because i obviously want to use the
camera settings in twin motion and not
mess with too much
i'm simply just going to move that wall
back five meters
click those two command i join them up
go back down to our grand floor plan
repeat that exact same step so
command i selecting all those extending
our roof back and also going
up to our ceiling extending that ceiling
all the way up and repeating that
finally for the top floor ceiling so now
we've extended that building
back as far as we can it's an enclosed
box that you're not going to see
anything off until you actually come
into this room itself
and you have that beautiful elongated
view so now if we go direct link you'll
see that i've been able
now to actually move back and see the
entire space
that i really want to see what we're
going to see is the flooring on this
rendered image
has a different consistent pattern every
i'd say 500 mil
so what we're gonna have to do is come
back to archicad go to our ground floor
plan
and basically start slicing that slab as
best as we can
so the best way i personally know how to
do it is to draw one line
use that line as a dashed line change it
to some odd color so we know we don't
need it
extend it both ways clicking once spread
it
500ml and then just basically
dragging it all the way across grouping
it
and we have basically our grid that
we're going to cut so now we select our
bottom slab and we just start using the
ax tool
to slice all the way through it and
there we go i've sliced them all i can
delete those grid lines come back into
our 3d
if i click on my floor plan you'll see
that i've got
different layers of this slab
so what i'll do is i'll actually click
on the second slab in
change the texture of that to simply the
next texture across
and then holding shift and control i'm
going to continue
that pattern all the way across and
there we have it we have two different
textures
of that wood paneling that we're going
to be able to now use in
twin motion so let's direct link that
once more and let's focus on this floor
we'll open up our side panel we can
either use the magazines
textures that provide some really really
nice textures or we can use the
materials on board
i think for this one we'll probably have
to use the magazine so we'll go to
magazines now i think it's probably best
that we select the plank
and we select something like a painted
wooden planks now i'm going to quickly
throw that paint of wooden planks onto
one of these central
timber elements to see what it best
looks like we're gonna have to
definitely manipulate a play with it to
really make it look
the best that it can do especially when
it's
that large there so i'll drop that back
down to about
point two point two is pretty decent
i'll open up the scales i'll rotate that
45 degrees and maybe we adjust that to
point three to see how we look and then
what i'm going to do
is just replicate that from the start
going to this one over here
moving that down to 0.2 and rotating
that the opposite way of 45 degrees
so they align in a v-shaped pattern then
i'm simply going to go to the eyedropper
tool
click on my color copy and paste
that selection to this one so our colors
match
perfectly and there we go if we slow
down a little bit on twin motion we're
going to be able to see
that our flooring is in that v pattern
now unfortunately we don't have those
express
joints in this timber like we want
that's shown
on this render and it's quite
disappointing because that black really
accentuates the flooring and the
differentiation in the flooring
so if we wanted to actually change one
of these
we could go into the settings and we
could change this texture plate itself
we could replicate that black express
joint in there in photoshop or something
along those lines
but that'll be a completely different
tutorial for the time being we're just
focusing on what's available to us
in twin motion so we're going to come
along and go back all the way out to our
materials and our met metal
and then we're just going to simply
select our gold metal
to change and accentuate this
gold here the gold is definitely a lot
darker so what we'll do is just simply
click the gold and drag that down a
little bit
it's probably got a bit more natural
daylight coming through than what we've
got
but that's okay it's not too much of a
problem whatsoever
we're now going to simply go back
through our materials
go to our ground go to nature change
this to a grassy ground so we have a bit
of a base texture to play with
we don't have to really focus too much
on it
i think this would look really nice in a
high gloss plastic finish
even though it would be timber high
gloss we'll go to our plastic
we'll move all the way down we'll paint
it to red i know it seems a little bit
odd but we're just going to simply
change that all to 255
and have a beautiful white reflective
staircase
the glass is really struggling to come
out here so if we come to our glass
setting we can probably put a reflective
glass panel in there and just reduce the
opacity
a little tiny bit so we get to see a
little bit of that glass
actually shimmering and shining through
i'll keep moving that opacity down to
maybe about
40 percent i think so we can still see
the glass
and still see everything else going on
now the biggest and most important part
of this render is obviously the tree in
the middle
so if we go to vegetation and
landscaping we'll go to miscellaneous
we're going to see we have a number of
different fallen tree stumps that we can
use
so we can start utilizing this fallen
tree stump
drag that all the way down so we don't
see any of the roots but we still have
that beautiful tree stump coming through
now to continue with the tree stump
theme we just want a couple small little
bushes around the edge of that tree
there
so they've actually used some very
tropical fern looking bushes
so if i come to our fern here and just
simply drag that size
all the way down tapping in my way
through to change the scale
0.5 to really make it quite nice small
and more realistic to what we're
actually looking for
so there we have our first one i can
hold shift
and click across to create a copy of
that right there
unfortunately it is going to duplicate
that to the full size and a different
size
every time so we are going to have to
have a little bit of patience here to
make sure all these
work really really well okay so i've
gone through and copied a few of those
little ferns through so we can use them
i'm also gonna
place a couple more different common
ferns just completely dragging them
all the way down to the smallest size
again replicating them across
i'll just make them an instance
replicate a few
so as we actually drag down the size of
one
they all actually dragged down in size
so there we have our first little fern
garden coming together
it's good to introduce a little bit of
color so if we select some of these
little guys
pop them through all the way through
just to really
make them quite small and give that that
landscape
a lot of color we can select the really
tall ones and just
simply drag their sizing all the way
down because they're
definitely way too large for what we
want it for we're starting to get our
garden
looking pretty decent inside our
foyer so now to extend this tree trunk
what we're going to do is click on that
tree trunk
tap our way through until we get these
squares and i'm going to drag it quite
far
up because i'm going to have to also
drag it a lot
lower as well to hide the tree trunk
so we have that snap tree trunk right
there beautifully in the middle
we want to showcase the features that
are broken so i'll rotate it a little
bit around
so we can see that in our lovely spiral
staircase as well
now what i've just noticed is we have no
actual landing
for us to get on these stairs so i'll
quickly delete all those
come back into archicad and create a
small little landing here from a slab
so we can actually step on our
stairs to do that i'll quickly just
create a simple slab
go to our draw tool and
just draw a simple landing slab in as
easy as drawing any other slab so then
i'll go back to twin motion direct link
we can see
we've now actually got a landing to step
up onto
these stairs but what we're missing is
some actual articulation in the room
so if we just go back to our objects we
can start playing with what we have
going into home let's start with living
room object we're probably looking for a
little bench something along the lines
of this
we can definitely utilize that i
hate the colors of that going into our
material
we can really spruce it up with
something a little bit different we can
change it to whatever we like
absolutely whatever we like i think i'll
keep it as a long pile carpet give it
that dark gray look so it ties into this
room
and we'll also introduce a picture from
our object so going back into home
i think pictures are in living room
and then under decorations so we can
select a beautiful picture to go right
above that
that's definitely too small so the same
thing we did with the tree
we're just simply going to drag it
extend it
make it a very large beautiful picture
that would look like something that's in
an art gallery really
the render is looking from a little bit
of an angle
so we're probably going to create our
render from this angle
here which means we have to do a little
bit of treatment to the back of this
room as well just to be able to give it
some sort of life some sort of texture
what i'll do
is simply give the walls a bit of a
pattern a little bit of
life more so than anything else so if we
go back into our magazine surfaces go to
wood
we can probably stick to the planks like
we did before but i'll select something
a little bit different
unfortunately our ceiling i think is the
wrong color so i'll quickly
just jump back in to archicad and change
our ceiling
to a completely different white texture
so i'll just pick a random color because
we're going to change it in
twin motion anyway now i think these
walls really need to be tied in with a
nice
dark color so maybe if we actually go
back to our materials
look for a nice metal that we can play
with potentially something like a core
10 steel
but in a more flat texture so
in our mega scenes we probably have a
nice concrete look or maybe a nice
timber look that we can experiment with
maybe we can go to our wooden planks
there's this nice charred
timber black plank that we can drop down
again to about a 0.2
texture rotate it 90 degrees so it's on
a vertical pattern
maybe make it .3 so we can start
seeing it 0.5 oh yeah maybe 0.4 is
probably the perfect
ideal pattern for it so we can see that
wood patterning
we can see that paneling we can see it
upstairs
and then we're just going to simply have
to change the materiality
of our ceiling so we do have
wall coverings we do have a plaster coat
ceiling that we can utilize
we can change that color we can have it
as a pink we can have it as a blue we
can have it as a
dark gray we can have it as a black if
we really want to tie that whole room in
which actually looking on it now i think
maybe a nice dark grey
would tie that room in really really
nice
so you have that beautiful accentuating
staircase moving up
with the central broken tree in the
center
now obviously i've detoured well and
truly from the original render
but that's the best thing about twin
motion you can play with it you can
manipulate it you can create it
however you wish however you like and
i'm finding this a lot nicer
and a lot more moody than what we have
already created on
this very gold very rich kind of donald
trump looking
render on the left hand side and there's
basically our first render all we're
going to do now is create our first
image so
let's go create first image and we're
going to change these settings to format
i like to change these settings of the
format to
2000 by two and a half thousand
because that lets us have the instagram
format that we're looking for
so if you're gonna post this you're
probably gonna post it on instagram now
we have the perfect instagram format set
up
i'm just gonna quickly refresh that
image and
i don't think there's really too much
more we can do we can maybe
just manipulate that location of how
we're really looking at that image
something along those lines there will
be a little bit better
we can go into more we can adjust our
camera settings
i like to zoom in when you go to to
instagram format to about 50
and then zoom all the way out
so we can see everything again in that
image
like we really originally planned on
and then going back into more going into
our lighting
going into our settings and just
bringing the ambience up that little bit
so we get a little bit more brightness
coming through in this image
so maybe leaving the ambience at about
1.5 is absolutely perfect
and basically that's completely finished
now all we're going to do is go file
save as because twin motion is notorious
for crashing before we export this image
okay now if you're still here with me
what i'm going to do is take this twin
motion export and take it into lightroom
to really make this image stand out
so we'll open up lightroom and all i'm
going to do is
drag and drop that image that we created
directly into lightroom itself now if
you've never used lightroom before
lightroom is a very simple program
it lets you basically manipulate all the
colors and shapes and textures of an
image
but the best thing about it is you can
create your own presets
now i have my own presets specifically
for twin motion exports to help you get
the best out of your images
so if you want to be able to simply one
click change
everything like you see me here
scrolling through these presets there is
a link down below
if you want to get them for yourself now
personally all of these presets actually
look really really good on this image
i think i'm liking the darker moodier
tones something like a winter internal
so i'll select that but what i will do
is bring out my shadows a little bit
and reset overall i think i'll also
simply paint out the bottom of the
flooring
so we can get some texture back into
that flooring as you see
a lot of that texture's really been
removed and there we go we have our
completed picture
our twin motion tutorial completely
finished and
a beautiful spiral staircase with a
broken tree
in what appears to be now our basement
instead of a beautiful
luxurious wine bar but hey that's the
fun of arcade24
that's fun of twin motion you can create
whatever your heart desires
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the two videos in one week
this week
something different it's something i
posted on the youtube community and you
guys told me that you wanted
these videos split in two instead of
being an extremely long video like they
have been in the past
let me know what you thought of this
format if you liked it if you didn't
either way i'm hoping you really enjoyed
the content and
are inclined to smash that subscribe
button and the like button for the
youtube algorithm
that's it for me so i will see you next
monday